hi everyone welcome to this next episode
of your daily equation and today I'm
going to focus on some some very basic
but very important very pivotal insights
into the workings of the physical
universe that forced us to cast our
minds pretty far back to say even as far
back as the late 1600s because I'm going
to talk about planetary motion the very
basic equations of planetary motion and
of course that means that the star of
today's episode is none other then let
me bring his picture up on the screen
there you see it Isaac Newton right
Isaac Newton this towering intellect who
was able to look at everything that had
come before him which were a collection
of interesting insights beginning to see
patterns in data looking at the motion
of planets and so forth and was able to
encapsulate those patterns those
relationships in some very simple basic
mathematical equations that gave us
really the first step into our modern
understanding of the physical universe
so these are deep and important insights
even though they don't use a whole lot
of fancy equations a whole lot of fancy
mathematics although I should say the
mathematics can get pretty complicated
in its own right now you know I can't
tell you the number of times and I
understand why I can't tell the number
of times if people say okay so who was
the better physicist was it Isaac Newton
was it Albert Einstein and I think the
best answer to that question is who
cares right when you're talking about
intellects that can pierce the obscuring
layers and see the true workings of the
world in the manner that Newton did and
the manner that Einstein did it doesn't
matter who's better there's so much
better there's so much more insightful
than every other person that really has
lit
that you know I mean there were other
great physicists don't get me wrong but
you know the ordinary physicists the
mere mortal physicist is is so less
powerful so less able to to do the kinds
of things that an Einstein or a Newton
did that we just stand in awe of their
greatness regardless of whether it's
Newton or Einstein these are the kinds
of intellects that come along whatever
once a century and to my mind I I just
take sort of a great great thrill great
pleasure in the fact that every so often
molecules can come together into a brain
and yield the insights that a Newtonian
brain or an Einsteinian brain can give
us and that to me is what what makes it
all thrilling I don't need to rank them
as one or two or who's better who's
second place so to speak so anyway let's
get into the subject em and the the
subject is planetary motion and just so
that we're say all on the same page let
me just give you a little visualization
to have in mind so we have a planet like
the earth it's in orbit around a star
think of it as our Sun and the goal is
to understand with mathematical
precision the motion of the earth or the
other planet Saturn Jupiter whatever we
want to write down equations that allow
us to predict where the planets will be
at any given moment and that's what
Newton does for us okay so let's get
into the subject I have to write down
some ideas and equations I need my Apple
pencil to do that which I do pass over
there sorry hang on one second that's
how it goes all right so let me bring my
iPad up on the screen good all right so
the subject then is planetary orbits or
really planetary motion more generally
and it comes from basic
laws of motion that Newton provided us
and how then does that go so as in the
animation say we have the Sun in space
and we have the earth say some other
location and let's say that the distance
between them is our and what Newton
tells us is that the force of gravity
and obviously it's one of the most
famous equations maybe it is the second
most famous equation to Einstein's
equals MC squared I don't think that
ranks Newton vs. Einstein that's public
relations as opposed to pure intellect
but the force of gravity that Newton
tells us is if the earth has mass little
m and said the Sun has mass Big M then
you take Big M I will not color code
everything will take me to long times
little m no putting all this colors you
know do it times G and you have to
divide this whole log through by R
squared so this is the magnitude of the
force of attraction between the Earth
and the Sun goes those the product of
the masses divided by the square of
their separation and it is an attractive
force I could write this as vectors but
let me just say as we all know that the
force of gravity and this guy's pulls
the Sun toward the earth earth toward
the Sun so it acts along the radial
direction drawing the two objects
together okay so what do we do with that
well we now make use of the famous
second law of Newton which says that F
equals MA and again one of the equations
that we teach to high school kids around
the world right now and and you know F
equals MA is a very simple looking
formula I should say F is the force him
as a mass is the acceleration but you
know I could teach a whole semester on F
equals MA there's a lot hidden behind
the scenes
F equals MA right because I mean what's
here what really do you mean by the mass
of an object what really do you mean by
the force on an object acceleration well
we talked about that as the rate of
change of velocity if you let me just
put down a little calculus for the heck
of it so acceleration just magnitude
comes from the rate of change of
velocity velocity is a vector in
circular motion so maybe I really should
put that down of that sort and you know
velocity itself comes from a similar
expression rate of change say of
position but immediately you see that to
even talk about these ideas we need to
commit to some understanding of time we
need to commit to some understanding of
space that's what the X is representing
and right there
there's deep issues what do we mean by
space what do we mean by time now Newton
took the perspective of hey these are
these are ideas that are so intuitive
and they're so clearly the basis of the
reality that we experience that he
basically just said you know space is
the arena within which things happen
period end of story he said time is this
quality that inexorably advances moment
after moment after moment in a manner
that's the same for everyone regardless
of where you are what you're doing what
you're experiencing and so he kind of
anchored this law of motion F equals MA
in an intuitive understanding of what we
mean by space and time and of course
when Einstein then came along later on
he was able to go further and say hey
the intuition that we have about space
and time is not actually correct it
works at slow speeds it doesn't work at
high speeds and therefore you see that
the subtleties that we immediately can
identify within even the simple Newton's
second law these are important
subtleties because thinking them through
clearly yields a new revolution
the revolution of special relativity
which we have covered in some previous
episode so it's just to say you know
when you see a formula like F equals MA
there's a lot behind that formula I'm
not going to get into any further of
those details now but maybe in one of
these episodes I'll actually take F
equals MA and and really pull it apart
and we'll think about all the
assumptions and all the qualities for
the world to go into that but for now
we're just going to of course make use
of it so if we now imagine and this is
the simplest case that we will study in
at the end of this episode I'll
generalize it a bit but if we imagine
say that the earth whoops let's draw
that like this it's so hard to draw
freeform so imagine that the earth is
going in circular motion we all know
that that's not quite right it's
elliptical motion I will come back to
that toward the end but to be simple
right now imagine that the earth is
traveling in a circle with the Sun at
the center then how do we make use of
these equations to work out the formula
say for the velocity of the earth around
the Sun well we make use of the
following fact if you have circular
motion then the acceleration is not
coming from a change in the speed of the
object circular motion we're going to
imagine it's at fixed speed but what
does change of course is here it is well
that's kind of sloppy let me see if I
can do a little bit better than that
with a different color so let's use some
hot pink here so this location I'm
overdoing it but you can see that there
is the instantaneous velocity vector of
the earth at some other location it will
then be tangent to the circle at that
location and you see that v1 and v2 they
have the same magnitude but a different
direction and so it's the change in
direction
remember velocity is something that has
both a magnitude and a direction it's
the change of direction and circular
motion that gives rise to the
acceleration and if you're careful about
looking at the change in the velocity of
that
as say the increment of time gets
smaller and smaller so that this second
factor gets closer and closer to the
first you can convince yourself it's
actually just a little bit of playing
with these vector you can convince
yourself that the acceleration is always
radially inward toward the center of the
circle and indeed if you're careful
about it the magnitude of that
acceleration is equal to V squared
divided by the radius and that's really
not hard to establish I'm not going to
take the time to do it here you can do
it in a manner that I indicated but now
we're cooking with gas because with the
equations that I have boxed over up on
your screen we can now find a formula
for the magnitude of the velocity where
we just are going to set the force
namely g m m mass of the sun mass of the
earth the distance between them r
squared that's equal to m times a but
for a we will now put V squared divided
by R and that's nice because the MS
cancel out which effectively always
happens in gravitational problems and
that is actually a deep insight that you
need general relativity to fully
appreciate but now we're just going to
use it as a mathematical fact that we
have here so that gives us V squared
equals G M multiply through by the R it
kills one in the bottom GM over R and we
have V for circular motion maybe I'll
put a C on it for circular motion is
equal to the square root of G M divided
by R so there is a simple and an elegant
little formula that allows us given say
the mass of the object say the Sun in
this case over here given Newton's
constant G given the distance between
say the earth and the Sun we now know
the speed that the Sun that the earth I
should say would have
it's moving in a circle around the Sun
now there's something else that that's
really cool that immediately pops out of
this so let me now use that in the
following way if I consider say the
period that it takes T the time for it
takes the earth to go in one full orbit
around the Sun well that will be
distance to PI R divided by the velocity
VC and I'm going to drop all the
constants now because I'm just really
trying to get at a proportionality as
we'll see in a second so let me just
write this as proportional to R over VC
and that's proportional to the VC the
only thing of interest in there for us
is the R dependence and it goes like the
square root of 1 divided by R leaving
out all of the fancy constants I just
want the proportionality and that is
proportional the square root of 1 over R
brings us a square root of R upstairs
r to the three-halves power and that
implies and now this is worthy of a
change in color make it even darker that
the period squared is proportional to
the radius of the orbit cubed and you
may be familiar with this relationship
because this is one of Kepler's laws of
motion
let me bring Kepler up on the screen
here so there's Johannes Kepler and what
Kepler did was and this is totally
amazing
Kepler's before Newton and what Kepler
does is he looks at the data that was
gathered by Tycho Brahe hey I believe it
was and he he just immerses himself in
the data careful measurements of
planetary motions planetary distances
and so forth and notices I mean you know
you have to play with these numbers he
notices and bring it back up on the
screen here he notices that if you take
the square of the period
or the orbit the orbit time of a planet
and you take the cube of its distance
from the Sun that there is this
relationship that seems to be apparent
in the data he doesn't know why this
would be the correct relationship
between the period of the orbit and the
distance of the orbit but he notices it
as a fact that just you know amazing in
its own right and then Newton comes
along and with these very simple
equations that we have over here he is
able to derive this relationship that's
throughing right there's this unexpected
pattern in the data square of the period
goes like the cube of the radius of the
orbit and then Newton using these simple
ideas is able to derive that so that
that's that's really that's really quite
beautiful there so so so far we've
gotten then is if we have let's go back
to my picture over here so if we have
the Sun over here and we have say the
planet the earth over here if we were
launching the earth into orbit and we
wanted it to travel in a circular orbit
we know that we would have to launch it
with a tangential speed be given by the
square root of g mass of the sun divided
by r and if we did that then the earth
would go into circular orbit but a
natural question is what if we don't
launch it with precisely that speed
squared of GM over R what would happen
and let me finish up our discussion here
today by discussing a number of
possibilities of what could happen for
the planetary motion and to do that it's
useful for me to derive one other very
important speed which is called the
escape speed escape velocity more
precisely and what is that well how much
speed would I need to give to the earth
to ensure that it actually doesn't go
into orbit at all that actually escape
all the way to infinity the son can
never pull it back and again this could
be your daily equation in its own right
this is kind of bonus material if you
will for today's daily equation but it
seems fitting to try to include it in
this episode so how would you work out
the escape velocity and the simplest way
to do that is to make use of the the
following facts so when we're talking
about the energy say of the earth or any
object Iraq that's in motion and the
vicinity of a source of gravity like the
Sun how would we write down that energy
well we write that energy in terms of
kinetic energy the energy of motion plus
potential energy which is the energy
again that some object has by virtue of
being near a source of gravity right as
I put the Apple pencil higher and higher
it has more and more potential energy it
will drop and it will achieve ever
greater kinetic energy as a potential
energy is transformed into kinetic
energy now for kinetic energy we know
the formula or I hope that you've seen
the formula if this is your first
introduction to this series you can go
back and see earlier episodes where I
discussed this but if not you can just
look it up so kinetic energy goes as 1/2
MV squared but what about potential
energy what is the potential energy
associated with the force of gravity and
that is not completely obvious again
that is something that might be worthy
of an episode in its own right but I'm
just going to write down the answer
which is minus g-m M divided by R and
this is known as the Newtonian
gravitational potential as a function of
the distance R and some of you will note
that if I take the derivative or
negative the derivative of this
potential with respect to R I will get
the force of gravity that Newton wrote
down so that is the relationship between
so-called conservative forces
forces that don't lose energy to
friction the relationship between the
potential energy function and the force
itself but again you know in all these
episodes it's hard to know where to stop
and the explanations because you can go
sort of all the way back to the ancient
Greeks if you follow the trail of what
depends on what so I hope you're okay
with me just writing this down at this
stage in the discussion today and how do
we make use of this formula well when we
talk about escape velocity what we
really mean is the Earth's say will
escape the pull of the Sun and when it
reaches infinity it will have exhausted
all of the kinetic energy that we pumped
into it in order to kick it out of orbit
now if it has zero speed at infinity and
that infinity of course R is large so
this number here will also go to 0 as R
goes to infinity and if this guy goes to
zero because the velocity is going to
zero at infinity and I'm just erased so
it's gonna be messy what we're saying is
to get the escape velocity we just set
the left-hand side equal to zero because
we want at infinity for the earth or
whatever object is escaping the Sun to
have zero energy can have zero energy of
course because this gravitational energy
is negative the way that we have set
things up again
itself an interesting idea worthy of its
own daily equation too but I'm not going
to follow that subtlety any further than
simply mentioning it ok so with this
equation here we can now write down that
1/2 MV squared equals G M M divided by R
again the ends go away the two goes over
so we get V squared equals to G M
divided by R in other words the escape
velocity let's call it ve is the square
root of 2 G M over R so that's kind of
interesting because to put the earth in
a circular orbit we needed to give it a
speed
square root of GM over R if you have
this one over here so for circular
motion squared the GM over R and for
escape it's the square root of two that
gets added in or multiplied into the
formula so the escape velocity is the
square root of two GM over R so now we
have two interesting speeds VC and ve
and I'm now going to ask myself the
following question so if I have the Sun
and I have the earth over here I want to
think about the trajectories that the
earth will follow if I give it a speed
for instance that is less than the
circular possibility V equal to the
circular number squared of GM over R we
know what happens there it will just go
into orbit then I want to consider what
happens if I give it a little bit more
than so this case over here I should say
obviously I'm giving it less than the
circular here I'm giving it equal to the
speed required to go into a circular
orbit what happens if I give it a speed
V say that's greater then the speed
required to go in a circle but say less
than the escape velocity right and then
I can consider V equal to the escape
velocity we know what will happen there
but I'm going to give a little bit more
detail and finally what if I give it a
speed V greater than the escape velocity
so in other words I've got five
possibilities here that are worthy of
thinking about one two three four and
five and I'm not going to do them in
that particular order rather let me
start and I'm going to do this visually
for you over here so let me start by
giving the speed equal to that required
for the earth to go into a circular
orbit
and they receive the earth goes into a
circular orbit fine
if I now give it the speed that's equal
to the escape velocity we see that the
earth is escaping but here's a thing
what's the shape of the trajectory that
the earth follows and the answer is
turns out you can work out the
mathematical equations based on what
I've given you already it's a little
more involved but the earth will follow
a parabolic shape out to infinity and if
I go the other direction it fills in as
you see the other side of the parabola
good so that's the case of V equal to BC
and V equal to V II what if I give it a
speed less than that required to put it
into a circle well as you see here what
happens is it goes into an elliptical
orbit and the Sun is actually at one of
the foci of the ellipses that they're
right most of the two foci of the
ellipse that's what happens in that
particular case now what happens if I
look at a speed that's between the speed
required to have a circular orbit and
the speed required to escape the pull of
the earth boom there we see it the earth
also goes into an elliptical orbit a
larger ellipse where now the Sun is at
the left most foci of the two foci for
that ellipse and finally we already did
V equal to V escape what if his V is
greater than the escape velocity and we
see of course it still escapes but now
the shape is a little bit different the
shape is a hyperbola and so what happens
is you have four possible shapes for the
trajectory of say a planet like the
earth that will be determined by the
initial speed the initial velocity that
we give it it can be circular which is
the simplest one that we worked out the
equations for it can be parabolic when
this speed is equal to the escape
velocity there are two ways in which you
get an ellipse and two is kind of
undercounting because for any speed less
than VC or for any speed between VC and
ve you get elliptical orbits which
ellipses are easier to get then circles
for circle you need one very specific
speed square to G M over R for an
ellipse if you have any speed less than
VC or between VC and V you get an
ellipse and that's why the planets are
in elliptical orbits nobody was there
exactly precisely fitting them to have
the speed required to go into a circular
orbit now there are other subtleties of
course when you have a planet orbiting
say the Sun they're actually both
orbiting their center of mass and so but
the planets are very light compared to
the Sun so I'm certainly suppressing
certain details but this is the basic
idea and if you have the greater the
escape velocity goes in this hyperbolic
trajectory oh and I should show you the
other side of the hyperbola boom now
it's going off the the other side as
well
now why these four particular shapes
again I'd love to do an episode on that
but these are all known as conic
sections what does that mean this would
be the final thing that I'll talk about
today and it just schematically noted so
if I take a cone write something say
that looks like this and let me just
give it a little bit of a shape like
that and if I was to take this cone and
slice it with planes at different angles
the intersection of the plane with the
cone would give me different shapes
right so if I cut it with a plane that
just goes sort of right across like this
that's the easiest one to picture over
here this one will just me a circular
cross-section of the cone as I've drawn
it but now if I cut it at an angle if I
tilt it a little bit I'll get an ellipse
if I tilt it more I can get a parabola
tilted even further I get a hyperbole so
the four conic sections an idea just
from geometry give the four possible
trajectories of a planet that's being
acted upon by Newtonian gravity which is
a gravitational force that drops off
like the square of the separation so it
really all comes down to
the formula that I wrote here earlier
that the force goes like one over R
squared now finish up with why is it 1
over R squared
well the best way of thinking about it
intuitively is I think the one that most
of you probably encountered in high
school if you have a body like the Sun
it's basically you can think about it
sending off roughly speaking these lines
of force right now these lines of force
Pierce I'm only drawing them in a plane
because that's all I can do here but in
reality right
they are piercing a three-dimensional
they're going through three-dimensional
space so they are piercing a
two-dimensional sphere not a
one-dimensional circle as I've drawn
these are piercing a one-dimensional
circle but in a three-dimensional
spatial case they are piercing a
two-dimensional sphere that surrounds
the Sun and the area of a sphere goes as
we know the area of a sphere in
3-dimensional space goes like well it's
4 PI R squared which means that the
density of the lines piercing that
sphere dropped like 1 over R squared the
density of lines drops like one of our
squared and the density of the lines
determines the strength of the force of
gravity so why does it go like a square
here because we live in a three spatial
dimension 'old or at least three big
spatial dimensions are the ones that we
are imagining this gravitational forces
permeating so look at all the ideas that
come into this the number of dimensions
of space the inverse square law comes
from that the relationships between
force mass and acceleration that bring
in themselves ideas about space and time
that ultimately coalesce to give us this
cool formula here the formula for the
speed required for circular motion we
can from that get Kepler's law the
square of periods goes like cubes of the
radius we get the escape velocity from
it as well and finally we have the five
cases which give us
the four shapes of trajectories the
ellipses the circle power Baalak and the
hyperbolic so it's a deep and and and as
you see a beautiful subject I've just
sort of only skimmed the surface of it
but that gives you the the basic idea of
the underlying equations that allow us
to understand the motion of the planets
okay that's all I wanted to talk about
today take care until next time this has
been your daily equation